let's look at some interesting posts uh
that i saw this morning on the david
pakman show
subreddit which you can find at
davidpakman.com
reddit more than uh what is the number
now more than 28
000 viewers and listeners of the show
now
subscribed to the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit a lot of people writing to me
after the first
day of the trump impeachment trial
number two
about the so-called chewbacca defense
after seeing
attorney bruce castor rant for 50
minutes trump's attorney bruce castor
ran for 50 minutes about
vinyl records that his parents liked the
political preferences of his parents
his friends in the senate and what kind
of relationships he has with them
a pre-revolutionary british law and all
sorts of things that have nothing to do
whatever
with the impeachment trial i got a bunch
of emails from people saying was that
the chewbacca defense and scrappy do
posted this uh to the subreddit saying
who believes that bruce castor
was attempting to use the chewbacca
defense
during yesterday's portion of former
president trump's impeachment trial
and pointing out that bruce castor's
speech was just
random facts and irrelevant things to
the actual defense of donald trump and
indeed the chewbacca defense is
a legal strategy there's actually an
entire wiki page
about the chewbacca defense the
chewbacca defense is a legal strategy
when a criminal lawyer just tries to
confuse the jury
instead of refuting the case and the
reason that this can work in
criminal trials is we have this standard
of uh reasonable doubt and
if a defense attorney can introduce
reasonable doubt any kind of reasonable
doubt
then they are a significant step closer
to securing an acquittal
for their client and so the idea of a
chewbacca defense would be
a prosecution comes together and makes a
case that's relevant and it's germane
uh to the facts and the complaint that
is being adjudicated
and a defense attorney can introduce
irrelevant facts stories confusion
and if you can get the jurors just
saying
well we had the case from the
prosecution and then we had the case
from the defense
even if the case from the defense was
irrelevant and didn't make any sense
if it makes the jurors feel as though
there's some kind of doubt as to what
happened even if it's because the
defense lawyer was talking about
chewbacca star wars vinyl records and
whatever
you can turn what might be a very good
case for the prosecution
uh into a confusing enough case that
maybe you get a juror to say i think
we've got to go with not guilty because
i'm still even confused about what it is
that took place
that's the that's the idea of the
chewbacca defense now
it shouldn't really apply um
to a senate impeachment trial where the
standards are different it is not a
criminal proceeding it is a political
proceeding uh the jury is not
you know six or twelve of one's peers
it's 100 u.s senators
so in any case that's the back story on
the chewbacca defense and it is in
practice i don't know that bruce castor
deliberately planned to go
up there and do a chewbacca defense but
it's ultimately what ended up taking
place
another interesting post on the
subreddit this morning
uh about the second impeachment where
user hohh
said the second impeachment will be like
the movie groundhog day
same type of honestly presented facts by
democrats as in the first impeachment
followed by the same lame falsehoods and
distractions by republicans
as in the first impeachment same
disappointing results
still needs to happen though and i hope
i'm wrong about the results now
you know in the first impeachment i was
saying pretty early
trump's not getting convicted and we
knew that because we knew that
they weren't going to have the votes you
need 17 republicans to say i'm going to
vote to convict
and we thought there might be somewhere
between one and four and in the end mitt
romney voted to convict on one of the
two
counts much the same way i know that
people get mad at me when i say this and
they they've been emailing me this week
saying david why are you
pre-judging what's going on and saying
there won't be a conviction
it's because we know that maybe there
would be
five very optimistically five or six
republicans that might vote to convict
uh on the single count in in question
here in the current impeachment trial
but we just know democrats don't have
the numbers we just
know i would love to be able to tell you
that it's too early
because every republican is going in
there planning to
evaluate the case made by the
impeachment managers and evaluate the
case made by donald trump's
attorneys and then going to decide by
weighing the evidence but that's not
what they're going to do we know that
that's not what what they're going to do
and remember that 44 members of the
senate already said they don't even
believe the senate
has the jurisdiction to do this trial
you think they're really open to voting
to convict donald trump of course not
so i know some people don't like it but
it's the reality and
uh donald trump will be acquitted the
question is will he be acquitted
uh with any republican votes going
against him
or will he be acquitted with every
republican vote in his favor
remains to be seen join the discussion
on the subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit